the people in this room like all of us
who are in politics
and they tried to keep him out he was a
member of snick
the student nonviolent coordinating
committee which really
launched welcome everybody very
haphazardly thrown together stream they
are close to voting on trump impeachment
they
voted to call witnesses earlier and then
didn't call any witnesses we'll talk
about that
the vote is upcoming um it's all
happening very very quickly so i'm glad
you're with me here of the
of black civil rights protesters college
students
i think north carolina at t and he saw a
picture of them on the cover new york
times and they were sitting in
at a lunch counter and he looked at the
picture and he said they
looked the way that i felt
they looked the way that i felt and he
said he had to go down south to
mississippi
and they launched the voting rights
movement that's where the phrase one
person one vote
comes from was not invented by the
supreme court they would go door to door
to try to register people to that
but anyway julian bond was part of that
movement
the student nonviolent coordinating
committee non-violence
it was the end and it was the means
non-violence
and he ran for he ran for the state
legislature in georgia
a path to other civil rights yeah i mean
just for kicks you know people are
asking how many republicans do i think
will vote to convict
i'm gonna say four i mean i i really
don't know it'll be
i i have no idea um but expecting a vote
relatively soon and so
they said the student nonviolent
coordinating committee is taking a
position against the vietnam war
you're a member of snick we're not going
to admit you because you took a position
against the vietnam war and the supreme
court in its wisdom said
you cannot prevent someone from
swearing an oath to become a member of a
legislative body because of a position
that they took or a group they were a
part of took before they got sworn in
that's the exact opposite of donald
trump he got elected to office
he swore an oath to the constitution
to preserve protect and defend the
constitution he served as president
for four years right up until the end
when he wanted to exercise his rights
under
the imaginary january exception and he
incited
a violent mob in insurrection to come up
here and we all know what happened
he is being impeached and convicted for
violating his oath of office that he
took he's not being prevented
from taking his oath in the first place
the first amendment on our side
he tried to overturn the will of the
people the voice of the people
he lost that election by more than seven
million votes
some people don't want to admit it
counsel for the president could not
bring themselves to admit that the
election's over
if you're just joining us we are in
closing uh closing arguments closing
statements in the second donald trump
impeachment trial trump the only
president to be impeached twice
uh trump um uh yes
a lot of other firsts but the one that's
relevant today trump the only president
to be impeached twice and we are
standing by for a vote expected very
very soon
um we saw a 55-45 vote earlier
two call witnesses and then no witnesses
were called and there's a lot of
different explanations as to why
uh house impeachment manager jamie
raskin speaking now
i see a lot of messages coming in and
we're going to have plenty of time to go
over everything chakaseki's saying david
i was surprised vanderveen didn't go
with the famous
philadelphia hoagie defense argument
yeah i was actually thinking they would
bring up bruce castor to debate the
merits of what is a sandwich but
i think it was raskin
mr president the majority leader is
recognized
mr president the senate is now ready
to vote on the article of of impeachment
here we go and after that is done
we will adjourn the court of impeachment
wow
this is it this is it the clerk will
read the article of impeachment
patrick leahy removing his mask for an
historic moment
a history and historic
and historic
yeah a lot of people denver denver
mccarthy wanted to hear bruce castor's
thoughts on pizza
there's just so much bruce castor could
talk to us about and it's it's really a
missed opportunity i would say
thanks anchovy for the twitch sub
appreciate it
we will see a full reading of the
impeachment article and then a vote roll
call vote 100 senators presumably all
hundred will vote
article one incitement of an
insurrection
senator the constitution provides that
the house of representatives shall have
the sole power of impeachment
and that the president shall be removed
from office on impeachment 4
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors
further section 3 of the 14th amendment
to the constitution prohibits any person
who has
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
against the united states from holding
any office
under the united states in his conduct
while president of the united
states and in violation of his
constitutional oath
faithfully to execute the office of the
president of the united states
and to the best of his ability preserve
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
and in violation of his constitutional
duty to take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
donald john trump engaged in high crimes
and misdemeanors by inciting violence
against the government of the united
states
in that on january 6
2021 pursuant to the 12th amendment to
the constitution of the united states
the vice president of the united states
the house of representatives and the
senate met
at the united states capitol for a joint
session of congress
to count the votes of the electoral
college
in the months preceding the joint
session president trump repeatedly
issued false statements
asserting that the presidential election
results with a product
of widespread fraud and should not be
accepted by the american
people or certified by state or federal
officials
she really should say for one before the
joint session commenced president trump
addressed
a crowd at the ellipse in washington d.c
there he reiterated false claims that we
won't
we won this election and we won it by a
landslide
he also willfully made statements that
in context including
a lot foreseeably resulted in lawless
action at the capitol such as
if you don't fight like hell you're not
going to have a country anymore
that's incited by president trump
remember something about hearing trump
quotes read by the clerk and monotone is
interesting objectives interfere with
the joint sessions
solemn constitutional duty to certify
the results of the 2020
presidential election unlawfully
breached and vandalized the capital
injured and killed law enforcement
personnel
menace members of congress the vice
president and congressional personnel
and engaged in other violent deadly
destructive and seditious acts
president trump's conduct on january 6
2021
they said sir you won by a lot
nation of the results of the 2020
presidential election
those prior efforts included a phone
call on january 2 2021 during which
president trump urged the secretary of
state of georgia
brad raphson's burgers to find rafson's
burgers yeah
susan collins thinks he's learned his
lesson guys everybody relax
security rappensburger if he failed to
do so
in all this president trump gravely
endangered the security of the united
states and its institutions of
government
a lot of people thinking 55-45 that's
interesting
with the peaceful transition of power
and imperiled a co-imperiled a co-equal
branch of government
he therefore betrayed his trust as
president to the manifest injury
the president got home and his wife said
sir i didn't see the event because they
were covering something about some
rainstorm
somewhere which i'm sure affected many
people but come on they've never treated
anyone as unfairly as they have treated
me
and has acted in a manner grossly
incompatible with self-government
and the rule of law donald john trump
thus warns impeachment and trial
removal from office and disqualification
to hold
and enjoy any office of honor trust or
profit under the united states
and demand that you the said donald john
trump
should be put to answer the accusations
as set forth in this article
and that such proceedings examinations
trials and judgments
might be thereupon had as are agreeable
to law and justice
each senator when his or her name is
called will stand
in his or her place and they'll vote
guilty or not guilty as required by rule
23 of the senate rules of impeachment
article 1 section 3 clause 6 of the
constitution
regarding the vote required for
conviction on impeachment
provides that quote no person
shall be convicted without the
concurrence of two-thirds of the members
president close quote the question
is on the article of impeachment
senators
how say you is the respondent donald
john
trump guilty or not guilty
a roll call vote is required and the
clerk
will call let's let's track republican
yays
ms baldwin guilty
mr barrasso mr barrasso not guilty
an historic moment mr bennett
mr bennett guilty mrs blackburn
mrs blackburn not guilty
mr blumenthal
mr blumenthal guilty
mr blunt mr blunt
not guilty vote happening now mr booker
mr booker guilty
mr boseman
mr boseman not guilty
mr braun mr braun
mike braun who slept says not guilty mr
brown
mr brown guilty mr burr
mr burr guilty republican richard burr
votes guilty
ms cantwell guilty
mrs capito mrs capito
not guilty mr cardin
mr cardin guilty
mr carper mr carper guilty
mr casey
mr casey guilty mr cassidy
mr cassidy guilty
that's the second republican right
cassidy
ms collins guilty susan collins guilty
that's three republicans
mr coons guilty am i am i right about
that
mr cornyn
mr cornyn not guilty
ms cortes masto miss cortes masto
guilty mr cotton
mr cotton not guilty loony cotton says
no mr kramer
mr kramer not guilty
mr crapo mr crapo
not guilty mr cruz
mr cruz shocking not guilty
mr danes mr danes
not guilty ms duckworth
ms duckworth guilty so i believe three
republicans so far
mr durbin guilty ms ernst ms
ernst not guilty
mrs feinstein mrs feinstein
guilty mrs fisher
mrs fisher not guilty
mrs gillibrand mrs gillibrand
guilty mr graham
lindsey graham graham not guilty shocker
huh mr grassley
mr grassley not guilty
mr hagerty mr hagerty
not looking good miss hassan
miss hassan guilty
mr hawley mr hawley
not guilty mr heinrich
mr heinrich guilty mr hickenlooper
mr hickenlooper guilty
ms hirono ms hirono
guilty mr hoeven
mr hoeven not guilty
mrs hyde smith mrs hyde smith
not guilty mr inhofe
mr inhofe not guilty
mr johnson mr johnson ron johnson guilty
mr kane mr
kane guilty mr kelly
mr kelly guilty
mr kennedy mr kennedy that's a
republican kennedy so people know mr
king
[Music]
mr king guilty
ms klobuchar there's amy
guilty clobbering mr lankford
mr lankford not guilty
mr leahy guilty mr leahy
guilty mr lee
mr lee not guilty
mr luhan mr lujan
guilty ms llamas
miss lumis not guilty mr mansion
mr novantian
mr markey mr markey
guilty mr marshall
mr marshall not guilty mr
mr mcconnell not guilty anybody
surprised
mr menendez mr menendez
guilty mr merkley
mr merkley guilty
mr moran mr moran
not guilty miss murkowski
ms murkowski guilty that's the fourth
republican mr murphy
mr murphy guilty i predicted five this
is murray
mrs murray guilty
mr ossoff mr ossoff
guilty mr padilla
mr padilla am i right for republican so
far
mr paul not guilty maskless rand paul
already leaving look at him go
mr peters he just walked right out rand
paul's such a loser
mr portman not guilty mr reed
mr reed guilty mr risch
mr rish not guilty mr romney
romney guilty guilty miss rosen five
republicans
ms rosen guilty mr rounds
mr rounds not guilty and with that
impeachment conviction becomes
impossible mr rubio
not guilty there it is mr sanders
mr sanders guilty mr sass
mr sass guilty 34 knows but ben sasse
number six
mr schatz sixth republican mr schumer
mr schumer guilty mr scott of florida
mr scott of florida not guilty
mr scott of south carolina mr scott the
scots can't be counted on not guilty
mrs shaheen mrs shaheen guilty
mr
not guilty miss cinema miss
cinema guilty miss smith
miss smith guilty ms stabenow
miss stabenow she's a democrat guilty mr
sullivan
mr sullivan not guilty mr tester
mr tester guilty mr thune
mr thune not guilty mr tillis
mr tillis not guilty mr toomey
mr toomey guilty that's a republican
mr tuberville not guilty mr van hollen
mr van hollen guilty seven republicans
guilty sofa
mr warner guilty mr warnock
mr warnock guilty ms warren
ms warren guilty mr whitehouse
mr whitehouse guilty mr wicker
mr wicker not guilty mr wyden
mr wyden guilty mr young
mr young not guilty
there it is former president trump
acquitted
only president to be impeached twice
acquitted twice only president to get
covid
only president to talk about flushing 10
or 15
times
only president to claim his wife refers
to him as sir
unless you had a script
only president to claim his replacement
will end energy and indoor heating
and cooling
the eas are 57
the nays are 43.
two-thirds of the senator is president
not having voted guilty
the senate judges that the respondent
donald john trump former president
united states
is not guilty as charged in the article
of impeachment
resigning officer directs judgment to be
entered in accordance with the judgment
of the senate as follows
the senate having tried donald john
trump
former president united states upon one
article of impeachment what is leahey
talking about exhibited
against him by the house representatives
and two-thirds of the senators present
not having found him guilty of the
charge
contained therein it is therefore
ordered
and a judge that they said donald john
trump be
and he is hereby acquitted of the charge
in said article
mr president majority leaders recognized
mr president
i send an order to the desk and the
clerk will report
ordered is it an adjournment directed to
communicate to the secretary of state as
provided
by rule 23 of the rules of procedure and
practice in the senate
when sitting on impeachment trials and
also to the house of representatives the
judgment of the senate in the case of
donald john trump
and transmit a certified copy of the
judgment to each
without objection the order will be
entered
majority leader mr president i move that
the senate
sitting as a court of impeachment on the
article against
donald john trump adjourn
sign a die and without objection the
motions agreed to the senate sitting as
the court of impeachment stands
adjourned
signing die and
could have order please the presiding
office
the acting sergeant-at-arms will escort
the house managers
out of the senate chamber in order
and there it is uh donald john trump
known to many simply as trump
uh has been acquitted a second time no
other president has been impeached twice
and he indeed has now been convicted the
house impeachment managers
led by jamie raskin will now leave the
senate as many of you know
the members of the house are not um
typically i mean i don't know if allowed
is the right term but they're not
welcomed they they have no place in the
senate unless invited
and that invitation has now uh wrapped
up
as the case may be um seven republicans
voting to convict but
in the end ten too short the the count i
have here is
richard burr
mr president mr president can we have
order
the senate is not in order and the
senate will be in order
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
senate being a period of morning
business with senators permitted to
speak therein for up to 10 minutes each
oh they're going into morning business
this should be interesting does any
senator seek recognition
senator from new york majority leader
mr president the case
of donald trump's second impeachment
trial was
open mr president can we have order
please
the senator's right the senate is not an
order
senate will be in order senate will be
in order
hey thanks for the raid hutch welcome
everybody joining from hutch's
stream thank you thank you mr president
the case of donald trump's second
impeachment trial
was open and shut right president trump
told a lie
a big lie that the election was stolen
and that he was the rightful winner by a
lot he laid the groundwork for this big
lie in the months before the election
he told the big lie on election night
and he repeated the big lie more than a
hundred times
in the weeks afterwards he summoned his
supporters to washington assembled them
on the ellipse whipped them into a
frenzy
and directed them at the capitol and
then
he watched as the violence i think
schumer's about to crush republican
colleagues
his own vice president fled for his life
and president trump did nothing none
of these facts were up to up for debate
we saw it we heard it
we lived it this was the first
presidential impeachment trial
in history in which all senators were
not only judges and jurors
but witnesses and some were sleeping
institutional crime
that was committed doodling reading
former president
inspired directed and propelled to mob
to violently
prevent the peaceful transfer of power
subvert the will of the people
and illegally keep that president in
power
there is nothing nothing more
un-american than that
there is nothing nothing more
antithetical to our democracy
there is nothing nothing more insulting
to the generations of american patriots
who gave their lives
to defend our form of government
this was the most egregious violation of
the presidential oath of office
and a textbook text textbook example
a classic example of an impeachable
offense
worthy of the constitution's most severe
remedy
in response to the incontrovertible fact
of donald trump's guilt the senate was
subject
to a feeble and sometimes
incomprehensible
defense of the former president unable
to dispute the case on the merits
the former president's council treated
us to partisan vitriol
false equivalents and outright
falsehoods
we heard the roundly debunked
jurisdictional argument that the senate
cannot try a former official
a position that would mean that any
president could simply resign to avoid
accountability for an impeachable
offense
a position which in effect would render
the senate powerless
to ever enforce the disqualification
clause in the constitution
essentially the president's council told
the senate that the constitution
was unconstitutional all right
thankfully the senate took a firm stance
set a firm precedent with a bipartisan
vote
in favor of our power to try former
officials
for acts they committed while in office
we heard the preposterous claim that the
former president's incitement to
violence was protected
by the first amendment the first
amendment right to free speech protects
americans from jail
not presidents from impeachment if the
president had said during world war
ii that quote germany should attack the
united states on long island
we've left it undefended i suspect
congress would have considered that
an impeachable offense finally
the defense counsel said that president
trump was not directly
responsible for the violence at the
capitol quote
his words were merely a metaphor his
directions were merely suggestions and
the violent mob was just a spontaneous
demonstration
but wind the clock back and ask yourself
if at any point donald trump did not do
the things he did with the attack
on the capitol have happened there's
only one answer to this question
of course not if president trump hadn't
told his supporters to march to the
capitol
if he hadn't implored them to come to
washington on january 6 in the first
place if he hadn't repeatedly lied to
them
that the election was stolen their
country was being taken from them
the attack would not have happened could
not have happened
january 6 would not have happened
but for the actions of donald trump
doesn't take a genius republican leader
of the senate said
the mob that perpetrated the quote
failed indirect
insurrection was on january
6 was quote provoked by president trump
you want another word for provoke how
about it in sight
yet still still the vast majority of the
senate republican caucus
including the republican leader voted to
acquit former president trump
signing their names in the columns of
history
alongside his name forever
january 6th will live as a day of infamy
in the history of the united states of
america
the failure to convict donald trump will
live
as a vote of infamy in the history
of the united states senate
five years ago republican senators
lamented what might become of their
party if donald trump became their
presidential nominee and standard bearer
just look at what has happened look
at what republicans have been forced to
defend
look at what republicans have chosen to
forgive
the former president tried to overturn
the results of a legitimate election
and provoked an assault on our own
government
and well over half the senate republican
conference
decided to condone it the most
despicable act that any
president has ever committed and the
majority of republicans cannot summon
the courage
or the morality to condemn it
this trial wasn't about choosing country
over
party even not that this was about
choosing country
over donald trump and 43
republican members chose trump
oh what's going on here
they chose trump that was weird
it should be a weight on their
conscience today
and it shall be await on their
conscience
in the future as sad as that fact is
as condemnable as the decision was it is
still true
that the final vote on donald trump's
conviction
was the largest and most bipartisan vote
of any presidential impeachment trial
in american history i salute
those republican patriots who did hey
guys
so right now we're being raided by an
anti-semitic
uh uh group of people wanting to talk
about
chuck schumer and israel and dual
loyalty and this stuff we're just gonna
ban all of it guys we're just not gonna
do it it's all getting banned every one
of you is getting banned
not sanction the former president's
congress
because if lying about the results of an
election is acceptable
if instigating a mob against the
government is considered permissible
if encouraging political violence
becomes the norm
it will be open season open season
on our democracy and everything will be
up for grabs
by whoever has the biggest clubs the
sharpest spears the most powerful guns
by not recognizing the heinous crime
that donald trump committed against the
constitution
republican senators have not only risked
but potentially invited the same danger
that was just visited upon us
so let me say this despite the results
of the vote on donald trump's conviction
in the court of impeachment
he deserves to be convicted and i
believe he
will be convicted in the court of public
opinion
he deserves to be permanently
discredited and i believe he has been
discredited
in the eyes of the american people and
in the judgment
of history even though republican
senators
prevented the senate from disqualifying
donald trump for any office
of honor trust or profit under these
united states
there is no question donald trump
has disqualified himself i hope
i pray and i believe that the american
people
will make sure of that and if donald
trump ever
stands for public office again and after
everything we have seen this week
i hope i pray and i believe
that he will meet the unambiguous
rejection
by the american people six
hours after the attack on january sixth
after the carnage and mayhem
was shown on every television screen in
america
president trump told his supporters to
quote
remember this day forever
what is going on now with c-span
got a back-up stream we can switch the
american people
to heed his work racist confederate
flags
flying through the halls of our union
remember the screams
of the bloody officer crushed
between the onrushing mob in a doorway
to the capitol his body trapped
in the breach remember
the three capitol police officers who
lost their lives
remember that those rioters actually
succeeded
in delaying congress from certifying the
election
remember how close our democracy
came to ruin my fellow americans
remember that day january 6th
forever the final terrible legacy
of the 45th president of the united
states
and undoubtedly our worst
let it live on in infamy
a stain on donald john trump
that can never never be washed away
mr president on monday we'll recognize
presidents day part of the commemoration
in the senate will be the annual reading
of washington's farewell address aside
from winning the revolutionary war
i consider it his greatest contribution
to american civil life
and it had nothing to do with the words
he spoke
but the example it set washington's
farewell address
established for all time that no one had
the right
to the office of the presidency that it
belonged
to the people what an amazing legacy
what an amazing gift to the future
generations
the knowledge that this country will
always be greater than
any one person even our most renowned
that's why members of both parties take
turns
reading washington's address once a year
in full into the record
to pledge common attachment to the
selflessness
at the core of our democratic system
this trial was about the final acts of a
president
who represents the very antithesis of
our first president
and sought to place one man before the
entire country
himself trump must be furious show
let the record show can't even tweet
about the history
and the solemn oath we swear to the
constitution
that there was only one correct verdict
in this trial
guilty and i pray that while justice was
not done
in this trial it will be carried forward
by the american people who above any of
us
in this chamber determine the destiny of
our great nation
i yield the floor
trump acquitted is the news lay he gone
we'll see if we hear from a republican
mr president the republican leader
sounds like mcconnell
january 6 was a disgrace
american citizens attacked their own
government
they used terrorism to try to stop a
specific
piece of domestic business they did not
like vile guy fellow americans beat and
bloodied
our own police they stormed the center
floor
they tried to hunt down the speaker of
the house
but they built a gallows enchanted about
murdering the vice president
they did this because they'd been
fed wild falsehoods
by the most powerful man on earth that's
what the trial was about because he was
angry he lost an election
that's what you just said not guilty for
former president trump's
actions preceded the riot
or a disgraceful disgraceful
you've you voted for election of duty
the house accused the former president
of quote incitement you just did too
that is a specific term from the
criminal law
let me just put that aside for a moment
and reiterate something
i said weeks ago oh that's rich
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
so he's making a semantic game it's a
semantic game
the people who stormed this building
believed they were acting on the wishes
and instructions of their president can
you imagine
and having that belief but
merriam-webster's third definition does
not
really of the growing crescendo
crescendo of false statements
conspiracy theories and reckless
hyperbole
which the defeated president kept
shouting into the largest
megaphone on planet
earth a lot of people getting banned
right now oh my god the issue
is not only the president's intemperate
language
it's crazy what's happening on january
6.
it is not just his endorsement of
remarks
in which an associate urged quote trial
by combat
it was also the entire manufactured
atmosphere of looming catastrophe
the increasingly wild myths myth
mcconnell almost seems to think trump is
guilty even of things beyond
just the impeachment count and yet he
voted not guilty
some secret coup
i are now president
now i defended the president's right to
bring any complaints to our legal system
the legal system spoke
the electoral college spoke
as i stood up and said clearly at that
time
the election was settled it was over
but that just really opened a new
chapter of even wilder
wilder and more unfounded claims
the leader of the free world cannot
spend weeks
thundering that shadowy forces are
stealing our country
and then feign surprise
when people believe him and do reckless
things
now sadly many politicians sometimes
make overheated comments or use
metaphors we saw that
that unhinged listeners might take
literally but that was different
that's different from what we saw this
was an
intensifying crescendo of conspiracy
theories
orchestrated by an outgoing president
who seemed determined
i can barely even keep up banning people
moderators on twitch and youtube i do
need your help here
our institution's on the way out
the unconscionable behavior did not end
when the violence actually began
whatever our ex-president claims he
thought might happen that day
whatever right reaction he says he
meant to produce
by that afternoon we know
he was watching the same live television
as the rest of us a mob
was assaulting the capital in his name
these criminals were carrying his
banners mitch should have been on the
prosecution his
flags and screaming their loyalty
to him
it was obvious but only president trump
could end this he was the only one
who could former aides publicly begged
him to do so
loyal allies frantically called the
administration
the president did not act swiftly
he did not do his job
he didn't take steps so federal law
could be
faithfully executed and order restored
no instead
according to public reports he watched
television happily
happily as the chaos unfolded
he kept pressing his scheme
to overturn the election
now even after it was clear to any
reasonable observer that vice president
pence was in serious danger
even as the mob carrying trump banners
was beating cops
and breaching perimeters
the president sent a further tweet
attacking
his own vice president right
now predictably and foreseeably under
the circumstances
members of the mob
seem to interpret this as a further
inspiration
to lawlessness and violence not
surprisingly
later even when the president did
half-heartedly begin calling for peace
this is a strong case against trump for
the right to end
you did not tell the mob
to depart until even later
and even then with police officers
bleeding and broken glass covering
capital floors
he kept repeating election lies
this is crazy and praising the criminals
in recent weeks our ex-president's
associates have tried to use the 74
million americans who voted to re-elect
him
as a kind of human shield
against criticism if you're just joining
us this is not mitch explaining why he
voted guilty
he voted not guilty and now he's making
the strongest possible case against
trump
shield against better than schumer's
speech quite frankly
anyone who decries his awful behavior is
accused of insulting millions of voters
that's an absurd deflection
74 million americans did not invade the
capitol
true
hundreds of riders did maybe a thousand
74 million americans did not engineer
the campaign of disinformation and rage
that provoked it one person
did wow just one and who is that
i made my view of this episode very
plain this is mitch's sort of last
goodbye to say
we're done with trump as a party
specific task
the constitution gives us a particular
role this body is not invited to act as
the nation's
overarching moral tribunal
we're not free to work backward from
whether the accused party might
personally deserve
some kind of punishment
justice joseph's story our nation's
first great
constitutional scholar
as he explained nearly 200 years ago the
process of impeachment and conviction
is a narrow tool a narrow tool
for a narrow purpose
story explained this limited
tool exists to quote
secure the state against gross official
misdemeanors inquiry
that is to protect the country
from government officers isn't that what
it would be
if president trump were still in office
i would have carefully considered
whether the house managers
approved their specific charge so he's
basically just saying even though trump
did the stuff
he's out of office so that's why i voted
not guilty
the president's speech probably was not
incitement however
however in the context of impeachment
the senate might have decided this was
acceptable shorthand for the reckless
actions
that preceded the riot
but in this case the question is moot
because former president trump
trump is constitutionally not eligible
for conviction but he can run again this
is a close question
no doubt donald trump was
the president when the house voted
though not when the house chose to
deliver the papers
brilliant scholars
argue both sides of this jurisdictional
question the text is legitimately
this is what you call an escape hatch
mitch mcconnell has just opened the
escape hatch
and he's exiting by saying it's a
procedural opposition he has
this reflection i believe the best
constitutional reading shows that
article 2
section four exhausts
the set of persons who can legitimately
be impeached
tried or convicted it's the president
it's the vice president and
civil officers
we have no power to convict and
disqualify a former officer yeah doctors
should really pay attention to this
if you get hit with a malpractice claim
just retire from medicine
before the actual thing goes forward
in court just you just use this
explanation
and all civil officers of the united
states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for and conviction
of treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors end quote
now everyone basically agrees that the
second half of that sentence
exhausts the legitimate grounds
for conviction
the debates around the constitution's
framing make that
abundantly clear
congress cannot convict for reasons
besides those
this is one of the most politically
shrewd things i've ever seen
from from mcconnell which is basically
he's
he's staying on the not guilty side as
far as a vote goes
he doesn't act to prevent trump from
running again
but he creates a sort of guidepost
for the republican party to say we are
really done with trump now and to try to
start the process of we care about the
debt and deficit and
religious freedom and trump what no no
no no we're
we're constitutional conservatives not
limit impeachment and conviction powers
and it has no limits at all
the house has sole power of impeachment
and the senate's sole power to try all
impeachments
would create an unlimited circular logic
empowering congress to ban any private
citizen from federal office
that's not an incredible claim that's
nutty it's nutty to claim that that
would that's what it would do but it's
the argument of the house manager seem
to
be making one manager said the house and
senate have
quote absolute unqualified
jurisdictional
power end quote
well that was very honest because there
is no limiting principle in the
constitutional text
that would empower the senate to convict
former officers
that would not also let them convict and
disqualify any private citizen
an absurd end result to which no one
subscribes article 2
section 4 must have force
it tells us the president vice president
and civil officers may be impeached
and convicted donald trump's no longer
the president
likewise the provision states that
officers subject to impeachment and
conviction shall be removed from office
if convicted shall be
removed from office if convicted
as justice story explained
the senate upon conviction
is bound in all cases
to enter a judgment of removal from
office
if applicable removal is mandatory upon
conviction
clearly he explained this is so dumb
that mandatory sentence cannot be
applied to someone who's left office
the entire process revolves around
removal if removal becomes impossible
conviction
becomes insensible
in one light it certainly does seem
counter-intuitive that an officer
office holder can elude senate
conviction
by resignation or exploration of term
an argument we heard made by the
managers
but this underscores that impeachment
was never meant to be the final forum
for american justice never meant to be
the final forum for american justice are
some real mental gymnastics
and removal
or a string got in his mouth intra
governmental
safety valve it is not
the criminal justice system where
individual accountability
is the paramount goal
indeed justice
story specifically reminded that while
former officials were not
eligible for impeachment or conviction
they were and this is extremely
important
still liable to be tried and punished in
the ordinary tribunals of justice
put another way in the language of today
president trump is still liable for
everything he did while he was in office
as an ordinary citizen unless the
statute of limitations is run
still liable for everything he did while
he's in office
didn't get away with anything yeah these
are the same republicans who said you
can't criminally go after or even
investigate a president for things they
do while in office
we have civil litigation and former
presidents are not immune from being
accountable by either
one
i believe the senate was not was right
not to grab power the constitution
doesn't give us
and the senate was right not to
entertain some
light speed sham process to try to
outrun
the loss of jurisdiction law and order
guys
it took both sides more than a week just
to produce their pre-trial briefs
speaker pelosi's own scheduling
decisions conceded what president
biden publicly confirmed a senate
verdict before inauguration day
was never possible
now mr president this has been a
dispiriting time
but the senate had done our duty
it's not right framers firewall helped
uh
held up again
on january the 6th we returned to our
posts and certified the election
we were uncowed we were not
intimidated we finished the job
and since then we resisted the climber
to defy our own constitutional guard
rails
in hot pursuit of a particular
outcome
we refuse to continue
a cycle of recklessness by straining
our own constitutional boundaries
in response he's disgusting
the senate's decision today
is not condone anything that happened
on or before
that terrible day well it may not but it
says if anyone else does it again they
also won't be held accountable
she did what the former president
failed to do we put our constitutional
duty
first
mr president the senator from maryland
thank you mr president
i take this time to explain why i voted
to convict so these these are going to
continue i do want to get caught up on a
whole bunch of stuff if you're just
joining us the senate did vote today to
acquit
donald trump in the second impeachment
trial only president to be impeached
twice
seven republicans voting to convict
those seven are
richard burr cassidy whose first name i
forget
is it is it uh constantine cassidy i
don't remember
cassidy susan collins lisa murkowski
willard mitt romney ben sasse and
pat toomey all republicans voting to
convict uh ending at 57 to 43
10 short of the number needed so many
people have been supporting the stream
and i really appreciate that we got a
raid from hutch who raised a whole bunch
of money for charity today and we love
that
i'm so glad people are here on twitch
and i hope you'll come back to future
streams
this of course will be the last stream
for this impeachment trial since the
impeachment trial is over
um thank you to i don't even know it
must be about two dozen people who
grabbed twitch subscriptions so let's
just call it 33.
people have also been just massively
dumping memberships at joinedpakman.com
and if you've been enjoying
the coverage for the impeachment trial
this would be a great time to grab such
a membership on my website let me just
quickly thank a few people here
uh bobby jean signed up at
jointpacman.com colin miltenberger
jamie hipsher not hipster hipster nicole
jo leif
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly
having a lot a lot a lot of uh
pronunciation problems here
thanks to all of you i very much
appreciate that and we do have that
coupon code above my head
joinedpakman.com
so many different super chats i can't
possibly get to them but i know people
enjoyed seeing them uh coming up and
down
um but few people asking whether trump
will run again i don't believe trump
will run again i don't think so
um i think he's going to be sick of all
of this stuff we did have to ban
a lot a lot of people during this
it's sad that we did a few of them are
asking to be unbanned let me just
quickly adjudicate these
um someone uh showed up today
and has never participated today but
they showed up and said your tears are
delicious
demon rats cry more libs
while burring the country they were
banned they appealed it with the message
f off crybaby demo rat so that is going
to be a perma
that's a perma-ban we're just
adjudicating these right now
um another user who has been
participating for a long time
saying uh something about i can't even
read most of these
antifa are secretly nazis
um law is about semantics you stupid
[ __ ]
uh they were banned and then their
unbanned request was law equal semantics
don't be a dumbass
we're that we're going to make that
permanent that's a perma-ban
um
you little c enjoy your echo chamber you
little c
see you okay that's just that's instant
permaban as well
we're just re these are real quick guys
we don't even have to pay too much these
are just so easy
um i'm being respectful and never
insulted
anyone personally please allow
dissenting opinions that's respectful so
we're gonna do one unban okay i'll do
one unban
so we we've caught up on unban requests
three are perma
and one we have uh reintegrated back in
let me just look at a few other super
chats saying you cannot convict trump
because you would have to have the
ability to remove him from office
is like saying you can't convict someone
of a crime if they're already in jail
that's a fair point yeah it's ridiculous
david would the gop of voted differently
if it was anonymous are they afraid yes
i don't know i can't say for sure
how many but if this was a secret ballot
more republicans would have voted to
convict than the number that did no
doubt about it
stand in the middle of fifth avenue and
shoot someone or incite a mob to attack
the capital and be acquitted by the
senate surreal and
sad very much so very very much so
it's a an extremely sad day but a
predictable one
a predictable one let's see here
so trump being acquitted isn't that
going to create a third political party
for trump
i hope so i hope trump does launch his
third party
um does this mean president biden can do
whatever he wants
i guess yeah i guess so
kazeem says he's saying file criminal
charges that's pathetic it is
a military general commits war crimes
during the trial at the hague they are
reminded
he's a retired general acquitted well
said
the gop just eliminated any remaining
belief in democracy in america this is
literally the fall of american democracy
streaming live
sad day danny thompson says is this
mitch mcconnell putting his party and
donald trump on notice
that they will deal with trump from
within the party i don't know
i don't know if that's what he's doing
the opposite of what the house
republicans did not do with marjorie
taylor green and her committee
assignments or only words
it's too early to know we have to wait
and see if that's really what they are
uh
planning to do big thank you to michael
messmer who just signed up at
joinpakman.com i really appreciate
everybody
we i think it's about 36 hours of
impeachment stuff that we stream this
week and
uh really appreciate the support and
everybody signing up on my website
i am planning i've been asked on
thursday
the gamestop hearings are taking place
i think it's gonna be nutty uh
the gamestop uh robin hood hearings are
on thursday
i do plan to stream those live and i
hope you'll join me for those make sure
you're following on twitch
and subscribe free on youtube just to be
notified when we go live on thursday
it's going to be a while it's going to
be going to be nuts i look forward to
seeing aoc
uh question folks uh thanks to kristin
martin
for signing up on my website as well
appreciate that
let's see i miss some super chats people
are angry
there is no chance we avoid going high
when they set the bar so low
anything we do is high compared to this
low bar set by trump
mcconnell lauding the senate for not
rushing a process to
outrun their jurisdiction regarding
impeachment in an unrelated note supreme
court pick
te amo paul says
roni graya trump will not go away he
will charge up his cult to go after his
enemies now
yes a lot of people making really
really good points all right everybody
trump acquitted the rare weekend stream
but it was too
important not to be here for it i
appreciate
everybody who joined me let's now send a
raid out
let's send it to uh let's raid grand
master hikaru nakamura over on twitch
that is going to do it for me but we
have so much more i mean it's crazy what
we have coming up this week also noam
chomsky will be a guest on the show
hello breaking noam chomsky will be a
guest on the show
so a lot of really great things coming
up alright guys we'll see everybody soon